Sex
is really strange.
Okay.
You asked people what's your favorite activity?
And if you ask people,
particularly college students,
particularly just fresh from spring break,
I've seen key movies.
Okay.
They'll often answer sex or some word that is synonymous with sex,
but there was a kind of a puzzle
about how much time we spend on sex.
And it turns out there is data on us.
So people say sex is your favorite activity,
but it turns out we actually know how much time the average American spends on
sex and the date.
I'm going to follow up more promise summarized by this in his wonderful book by
James Gleick.
Um,
Americans tell polars their single favorite activity is sex in terms of
enjoyability.
They rang sex ahead of sports,
fishing,
bar hopping,
hugging and kissing,
talking with the family,
eating,
watching television,
going on trips,
planning trips,
gardening,
bathing,
shopping,
dressing,
housework,
dishwashing laundry,
visiting the dentist and getting the car repaired.
On the other hand,
these same studies suggested to average time per day devoted to sex is four
minutes and three seconds.
Yeah.
As Blake says,
this is not much,
even if the four minutes is excludes time spent,
flirting,
dancing,
oogling,
cruising the boulevard,
toning up in Jim's,
toning up in beauty parlors,
rehearsing pickup lines,
showering,
thinking about sex,
reading about sex,
doodling,
pornographic Lee,
looking at erotic magazines,
renting videos,
dreaming of sex,
looking at fashion magazines,
cleaning up after sex,
coping with the consequences of sex building towers or otherwise we're pressing
transferring and sublimating.
And
I like this passage because it illustrates two points,
two important points.
One is we don't actually spend that much time on sex.
In fact,
a four minutes and three seconds is an interesting number because when you went,
when you do time studies on how much Americans spend filling out tax related
forms for the IRS,
it's four minutes and a few seconds.
Um,
but the passage also points out that regardless of the brut time we spend on it,
it is extraordinarily important.
Um,
everything in life follows from it.
Marriage,
family,
children,
much of aggression,
much of competition,
much of art and music and creative pursuits.
Much of everything follows from it.
If we were a creature without sex,
everything would be different.
And what's interesting is there are creatures without sex.
There are creatures that reproduce by cloning,
and in fact,
this basic fact about people that we fall roughly into males and females is a
evolutionary mystery.
Um,
it's not clear why animals that are somewhat large have to sexist from a
biological Darwinian perspective,
having two sexes is bizarre because each time you have an offspring,
you toss away half your genes.
My children only have,
each of them have half my DNA.
If I was to clone,
they would have all of it,
and so it's a puzzle.
How sex ever evolved.
This is not a course in evolutionary biology and that's not the puzzle we're
going to be looking at today.
When I look at a few questions,
first,
we're going to talk from first a theoretical point of view and then an empirical
point of view about how males and females are different.
Then we're going to talk about sexual attractiveness,
some research about what people find to be sexually attractive and all talk a
very little bit at the end of the origins of sexual preference.
Why some people are straight,
others,
gay,
bisexual and others harder to classify.
Um,
now of all the topics I'm presenting,
sex is one of the sort of dicey ones from an emotional point of view.
These are difficult issues because sex is by definition an intimate part of our
lives and it matters a lot.
Moreover is fraught with moral implications.
And since I'm talking about this from at least at the beginning,
from a Darwinian evolutionary perspective,
um,
I'm obliged to start off by dealing with some of the moral consequences and
moral implications.
So for instance,
many biologists,
all biologists,
I would say we'll have argued that,
um,
that sexual behavior,
sexual action,
sexual desire is to some extent a biological adaptation existing to spread our
genes from that perspective.
Then non procreative sex including,
um,
gay sex,
sex with birth control,
sex by postmenopausal women,
um,
does not serve this reproductive goal.
And in some sense perhaps is unnatural.
And one might argue then does this mean it's wrong?
We'll also be talking about sex differences,
differences between men and women for instance,
in um,
in how much you want anonymous sexual encounters,
differences between men and women in social intelligence,
in aggression and empathy.
And regardless of what you think about these differences,
whether you think they're right or wrong or it doesn't matter,
you'll ask the question to what extent are they immutable?
That is if they exist through Darwinian natural selection,
to what extent
can we ever get rid of them?
And I want to address those two issues,
issues of morality and inevitability,
um,
from the very start.
And I want to start off with,
um,
with,
for each of them have a quote by a prominent evolutionary scholars.
So the first one is by Steve Pinker in how the mind works.
And he writes,
nature does not dictate what we should accept or how we should live our lives
well into micro procreating years.
I am so far voluntarily childless,
having squandered my biological resources,
reading and writing,
doing research,
helping out friends and students and jogging and circles,
ignoring the Solomon paired up to spread my genes by Darwinian standards.
I am a horrible mistake,
a pathetic loser,
but I am happy to be that way if my jeans don't like it and go jump in the lake.
Pinker's point I think is a reasonable one.
Um,
it is true that certain things we do exist to serve the dictates of natural
selection,
but that doesn't make them right.
Um,
if you think that something is only right,
if it leads to the generation of more jeans,
if it leads to reproduction,
then you're not going to think very much about birth control.
Um,
you're not going to think very much about any sort of non procreative sex.
On the other hand,
if you're more over,
if you think something's wrong,
if it's,
if it's unnatural,
you're not going to think much about flying in a plane or refrigerating food or
surviving a severe infection.
More generally,
our bodies and brains have evolved for reproductive success,
but we can use these brains to choose our own destinies.
Nothing moral necessarily follows from the facts of biology.
That's all I'm want to say about morality,
but I want you to keep it in mind when we discuss different claims about what's
evolved in what hasn't.
What about inevitability?
I'm here.
I want to turn to Richard Dawkins Dawkins rates.
If a child has had bad teaching in mathematics,
it is accepted.
The resulting deficiency can be remedied by extra good teaching in the following
year,
but any suggestion that the child's deficiency might have a genetic origin is
likely to be greeted with something approaching despair.
If it's in the genes,
it is determined and nothing can be done about it.
This is pernicious nonsense on an almost astrological scale.
Genetic causes and environmental causes are in principle,
no difference from each other.
Some may be hard to reverse.
Others may be why did jeans,
what do genes do to deserve their sinister juggernaut?
Like reputation?
Why are gene thought to be so much more fixed and inescapable and their effects
than television nuns or books?
I liked the nuns.
And the point here is
what causes something is logically separate from what can reverse it.
And you could think of clear cases where something is plainly Jeanetta but it's
fairly easily reversed and where something is cultural and it's very difficult
to reverse.
Here's an example.
My eyesight is quite poor.
The reason why my eyesight is quite poor is not due to the patriarchy.
Television culture are the man rather.
My eyesight is quite poor due to the crappy genes mum and dad gave me.
It is genetically determined.
If anything is,
it is also fairly easy to fix or these machines,
um,
where they put panes of glass in front of your eyes and help you to see better,
more advanced machines known as contact lenses actually stick the thing into
your eyes.
And at the cost of occasional infections you learn to,
you become to see better.
It is biologically caused but fairly easy to fats.
On the other hand,
take an example of society's treatment of the obese.
It turns out when we,
and we will get to this a little bit,
when you talk about sexual attractiveness,
how thins somebody is or how fat they are,
what you think of that is actually not particularly hardwired.
It varies a lot from culture to culture,
but once it's in a culture,
it is almost impossible to shake.
So the point there is just that genetic does not mean inevitable and cultural
does not mean easy to fix.
Okay,
that's general background.
Let's start with basic sex ed.
What's the difference between males and females?
Well,
don't even think penis in vagina.
Uh,
there's a lot of animals that have neither one.
And the difference actually runs deeper by definition.
When biologist talk about this,
um,
animals that are males have a little sex cell,
which carries genes and nothing else.
Sperm cells,
animals that are females have a big sex cell,
which has genes,
but also food and a protective cover and all sorts of other stuff.
Typically the little sex cell is much littler than the big sec.
So this is the only erotic picture I'm going to show you today.
It's a bunch of the little sperm circling around
the egg.
It's romantic.
Um,
this raises a puzzle I just described.
Male and female roughly in terms of a size difference,
males to smaller I'd sex cells,
females are the bigger,
why is it then that for so many animals,
males are the bigger ones physically and the more aggressive ones.
This has been a puzzle that is occupied scientists for a long,
long time and we're pretty,
there is now a pretty clear answer to it.
And the answer goes like this.
It is based on idea by Robert trevors call parental investment and what parental
investment is.
It's defined here as any investment that's going to increase the offspring's
chance of survival at the cost of the parents' ability to invest in other
offspring.
So for example,
suppose an animal could create an offspring by blinking an eye and an office
from the run off.
That'd be extremely little investment.
Suppose another animal had to work for 10 years and during those 10 years could
not create another offspring that it'd be a huge investment.
Trevor is points out that within a species,
females typically have a much higher parental investment then males,
because females have these big sex health,
they typically,
you incubate them internally,
they carry them.
If their eggs,
they might have to sit on them.
And hence each potential child is a huge cost for males,
which had the small sex cell.
You don't have the same thing for males.
Um,
it might just be a few moments of,
of copulation and that's it.
If you could ask yourself for humans,
each one of you in the room,
what is the minimum effort you can do to create a child that has half your
genes?
And it's apparent that the male investment on average is lower than the female
investment.
Males can choose or might do better off in some circumstances,
right?
Putting a lot of investment in their offspring,
but females don't have a choice.
Female's barring technological advance.
Um,
have a huge investment into any offspring.
not investment in a sense of hard work and effort though there's that too.
Um,
investment in the sense that when you're,
when you're the jest,
when,
when you're having,
when you're pregnant with one offspring,
you can't have another,
what this does is it has ramifications that perculate upwards.
So
it leads to different psychologies.
Males as single male could fertilize several females forcing some males to go
may list and giving rise to competition
to see who could mate with the most females.
For females,
however,
females can always find mates.
So sheer numbers don't count.
But there's competition to me with the right males,
those his offspring have the best chance of surviving.
Um,
the competition now explains the puzzle we started with.
It explains why males are typically larger and often why males have evolved
special weapons.
These special weapons evolve for fighting other males for reproductive access.
It also explained something else.
Females biologically are choosy.
And so males have to compete not merely with other males to,
um,
to,
to get reproductive access,
but also to Wu females.
And so often males have evolved special displays like this which exist only to
be beautiful,
only to be attractive and to attract mates.
Um,
does Cole evolutionary logic was captured in this cartoon,
which really does sum up a hundred years of made selection research.
The logic goes like this.
Then difference in the size of sex cells leads to differences in typical
parental investment leading to differences in the sorts of psychological and
physiological mechanisms that are well,
okay,
that's a good story.
What sort of evidence is therefore it?
Well,
it turns out this could explain some otherwise surprising things.
For instance,
there should be,
there are some cases where the parental investment is switched,
some cases where it turns out where the males end up with more investment than
the females and it,
and the theory predicts that in these cases you should get an asymmetry.
So in cases like pipe fish for instance,
the mail takes the eggs into a pouch and plugs them into his bloodstream.
The females shoot off.
They have less of an investment than the males.
In this case you would predict as is true,
the females should be larger.
The females fight other females more than males fight males and the females try
to compete for the attention of the males.
Recall the movie march of the penguins,
we saw a clip from it and this was in the context of discussing the emotions
that have evolved towards our offspring.
But remember the story and how both the male and a female have to go to
tremendous lengths to protect the egg.
And if one of them fails,
the egg dies and neither one has it.
You should then not even have to remember whether male females are much bigger
than female penguins.
You should realize they should not be.
And in fact they aren't.
They're about the same size because it,
the parental investment is equal.
You should be able to predict the size differences and aggression differences
based on differing parental investment.
So for instance,
um,
elephant seals are four times.
The males are,
are enormous.
There are four times bigger than the females.
And this is in large part because elephant seals compete for harems of females.
It's a winner take all.
Yeah.
Gibbons are about the same size and this is because Gibbons are pretty
monogamous.
They raised children together.
This illustrates something which is,
it's not always the case.
Um,
that male parental investment,
okay.
Is Low.
There are some species including Gibbons where it's in a male's reproductive
advantage to care for the offspring.
Imagine a situation,
for instance,
where an offspring would die if both parents didn't watch it for many years.
Okay.
And where the effort devoted had offspring had to be exclusive.
If you focus on another family or went away,
the offspring would die.
In that case,
you'd have equal investment.
It would matter equally to the male and the female to invest in their offspring.
And the cost would be the same.
Okay.
There is no species as hard as these species that have that much of an equal
system,
but some primates or close to it.
And this raises the question then.
What about humans?
What about us?
What do we know about the differences between males and females?
Well,
um,
humans are relatively polygamous species.
Most cultures,
most human cultures are,
um,
are polygamous American culture is what they call serial monogamy.
So we're not like some species of birds.
We don't mate for life.
We do a series of peer bondings for some period of time.
It could be for life,
but it need not be an usually isn't
males are bigger than females.
Okay.
Human males,
the size estimates vary so much,
but the average human males,
but 15% larger than an average human female.
This suggests that there are some May.
There's been in our evolutionary history,
some male male competition,
um,
for access to females,
which suggest in turn that the parental investment is not quite equal.
Um,
males have smaller testicles for their body size than chimpanzees,
but larger testicles than gorillas and givens.
Um,
and this suggests that there was some intermediate amount of competition for the
capacity to create sperm.
And this is relevant for a different sort of competition,
which regards to impregnation of females that have multiple mates
suggests that over evolutionary history,
women were not wantonly promiscuous,
but we're not entirely monogamous either.
So much so that,
that it paid from an point of view you to evolve males to evolved the capacity
to produce more sperm than other males.
Aggression.
Males are meaner.
I mean,
I'm summarizing here mean there's not a technical term.
Yes,
females can be meaner,
but males are at least more physically violent.
There are more violent in the room.
In utero,
they're more violent as children and there are more violent as adults.
Um,
again,
this is not to say that you can't find violent women or nonviolent men is just
on average.
There is this difference.
Um,
they kicked more males kick more in the uterus as children,
they're more involved in play,
fighting and violent combat like sports.
And as adults,
wherever you go,
you will find a prison and wherever you go,
you will find that prison is mostly fill full of men.
Um,
they are far more likely to kill one another and to harm one another.
male sex hormones tests like testosterone are the sword,
not the sort of thing one would want to inject in somebody unless you want them
to turn kind of mean it.
They increased aggressiveness both in humans and other primates.
What about sexual choosiness?
Do male humans and female humans differ in the extent to which they will favor
anonymous sex?
And this is relevant from an evolutionary perspective because the parental
investment theory predicts males should be more receptive to anonymous sex
because,
um,
for males to impregnate somebody else,
my fortuitously lead to another offspring.
It might be good for you and doesn't carry the sort of harm that females and
another unhappy,
very picky because they have to choose carefully.
Remember,
these systems evolve before birth,
birth control and vasectomies and so on.
So what do we know cross culturally and psychologically?
Well,
prostitution is a universally near our near universally male.
Um,
interest.
There are male prostitutes of course,
but contrary to some various fantasies and sitcoms,
they cater to male customers.
Pornography is a human universal.
Every in every society,
uh,
males have done some sort of depictions of naked females for the purpose of
arousal.
Often they carved them into trees or do sort of sculptures.
One of the weirdest findings in the last decade or so is that this extends as
well to monkey porn.
And so some scientists that Duke set up a situation where monkeys could pay in
fruit juice by giving a fruit juice to look at a picture either of a female's
hindquarters or of a celebrity monkey,
a socially dominant monkey,
some sort of combination of people magazine and Penthouse.
And um,
so there have some interest in this even by nonhuman primates.
Yeah.
What about actual preference for sexual variety?
Well,
you couldn't get at this in different ways.
Um,
there is what biologists describe as I'm the Coolidge effect have this here and
the Coolidge effect is based on President Calvin Coolidge.
And it's a story about Calvin Coolidge and his wife who were being shown around
a farm separately and a person showing around.
His wife pointed out that there was a lot of hands,
Gigi,
she noticed that there's a lot of hands but only one rooster.
And she asked the guy showing her around is one rooster enough?
And the guy said,
well,
you know,
the routes to works very hard.
The rooster has sex dozens of times a day.
And she said,
well,
be sure to tell that to the president.
Story goes present.
When around date,
the guy tells the story to the president.
The president asked,
a man has sex dozens of times each day,
same hand every time.
Okay,
says no different hen every time.
And he says,
tell out to Mrs Coolidge now.
Now there's two responses to this sort of story.
And they're both kind of negative.
One thing is,
well everybody knows males prefer anonymous sex with strange women.
The other response is that sexist clap trap.
You might think you might be a male and say,
that's not me.
You might know males and say,
the males I know are not like that.
So how do you find out?
Well,
there's indirect measures such as who goes to prostitutes,
but it was also fairly direct measures.
One fairly direct measure is,
um,
is you could ask people in anonymous surveys.
So in fact,
I'll give you some anonymous surveys.
I'm not going to ask people,
and you just asked him.
So you,
so,
so for instance,
I want everybody to consider this question.
How many sexual partners you want to have in the next month?
What does it coming up to April?
How many sexual partners you want an April.
Yeah.
Okay.
Next two years.
Take many of you through graduation when you leave.
Yeah.
What do you want to,
I had x sexual partners and that's what I wanted.
Or your lifetime.
We get people to answer these questions.
Um,
professor Chen last year in this course had clickers and it got people to now to
do it.
We are not so high tech,
so we'll just do it in our heads.
But here's the way the answers come out.
Yeah.
Women say less than one in next month.
That doesn't mean they want less than one.
That means many of them isn't that many of them say zero.
Some say one.
So on one four to five men to eight
18,
you can ask other questions from this population.
So you could ask,
when you have sex with a desirable partner,
you have known,
so it's gonna be really desirable for a year.
And women say yes,
six months,
I'm sure.
Week or less,
no men.
And
well then you could get a majority going down.
Um,
two to five minutes.
Okay.
This is all Q and a pen and pencil sort of things.
Some brave scientists have actually done experiments.
Um,
and in one experiment,
somebody,
I don't,
you know,
this is sort of thing which you probably wouldn't do nowadays.
This work has been done 10 years ago where they have an incredibly attractive
man,
incredibly attractive woman,
and they approach people on campus.
They're not from campus there,
they're actors brought in and they go to people,
to strangers and they say,
I've been noticing you around campus.
I find you very attractive.
Would you go out with me tonight?
Would you come over to my apartment tonight?
Would you go to bed with me tonight?
The experiment you wouldn't think anybody would have done has been done.
And women hate about a true,
very attractive man.
Over half of the women approach say,
yeah,
I will very few agree to this and nobody agrees to this for men.
The data are like this.
They go up to there.
Okay.
In the study,
the 25% of males,
um,
who said no apologize profusely.
And he said,
Oh,
you know,
my fiance's in town until you guys.
Yeah.
What about behavior?
Well,
you,
if we're interested in sex differences,
um,
you can't actually figure out what people want male,
female differences by looking at simply at the average number of times people
have sex because if male and females have different priorities than heterosexual
sex is a compromise between two groups of people with competing interests.
Um,
what's a more clear reflection then is gay sex between women,
between two women are between two men because then you get a pure reflection of
um,
of sexual desire.
Now the data here tend to be very messy.
Again,
there are surveys studies,
but by and large,
every study done tends to find a difference in the expected direction,
which is that females tend to be,
lesbians tend to be much more monogamous than gay men.
Um,
some studies prior to that,
prior to aids,
and this was many years ago,
found game and to be extremely promiscuous,
often having over a hundred,
over a thousand partners,
you wouldn't find this sort of promiscuity in female and females.
And the way to think about this is what these gay men are doing is exactly what
your average heterosexual man would do if he had that degree of willing females
who were as willing as he was.
And this all suggests that there's some sort of difference along lines expected
in sexual choosiness in humans.
What about sexual attractiveness?
What about made preference?
What do we find attractive?
Well,
unlike the choosiness studies here,
we actually have some pretty good cross cultural data.
So one study for instance was done in 10,000 people from 37 countries asking
people who you'd want to,
who you want to be with.
And there's different studies.
Some of them ask me,
who do you want to marry?
Other studies?
Who Do you want as a maid?
Who Do you want as a sexual partner?
And one main finding is
kind of reassuring.
Everybody likes kindness and intelligence or at least everybody says they like
kindness and intelligence.
These are valued pretty highly,
but at the same time,
there are sex differences.
Um,
females focus more on power and status and more on interest in investing in
children.
And think about that from an evolutionary point of view.
It makes sense.
It doesn't matter hugely from the standpoint of reproduction,
how old the managers,
the difference between 15 and 25 and 35 and 45 may matter a lot for a status in
the community,
his physical strength,
his lifespan.
But from the standpoint of his sperm,
it doesn't matter hugely.
Later on there's a drop off and it does begin to matter,
but it doesn't matter hugely.
Um,
what does matter is this interest in being a good father in protecting you from
predation,
from murder,
from assault by other people and in taking care of the kid.
Women's brains are wired up to find males with those properties.
Similarly,
males focus a little bit differently.
They're more interested in all of these things,
but also an ability to have children.
So from an evolutionary point of view,
there is actually a very big difference between a 20 year old and a 50 year old
from a male standpoint,
looking at a female because the one can have offspring and other cannot.
So this is a difference.
But what I want to focus more on right now is back to another similarity.
Everybody likes beauty.
And I want to devote a little bit of his lecture to talking about physical
beauty.
Physical beauty as these beautiful people say is a curse.
So she,
she's a like a,
a big model,
a supermodel,
maybe even a super super model.
Um,
points out the arbitrariness of finding her devastatingly beautiful,
famous actor pointed how frustrating it is that people only ignore his
accomplishments and focus merely on his physical beauty.
It's just very frustrating.
Um,
so,
so what is beauty?
What does this mean when we say we find,
wait,
you know,
yeah,
they really are very attractive people.
What is it about that that makes you look and say,
yeah,
that makes sense?
Well,
we kind of know the answer.
We know some universals beauty seems to signal to things you need seems to
signal youth.
I mean not preschool youth but,
but,
but youth like sexually,
sexually mature but young.
Um,
and so the cues we find uniform are cues to that large eyes for lips,
smooth,
tight skin,
beauty signal,
something else.
Beauty is a marker for health.
And so what we find beautiful things like the absence of deformities,
clear eyes,
unblemished skin,
intact teeth,
it's very big and an average face.
And that'll last part might seem a little bit strange.
What would it be so good about an average face?
And there's different answers to that,
but one answer is,
um,
an average face on average should be considered attractive because any sorts of
deformities are variations from the average.
And if you average every face together,
you get a face.
That's that we're nothing bad has happened to it.
There's no distortions,
there's no deviations as one gets older to face,
gets less symmetrical and so on.
Averageness seems to factor at all of that things that can happen.
Good theory.
How do we know it's true?
Well,
there's a photo roster that come,
that I have access to for this class,
so I can look at each of your pictures and I will make you a bad about who has
the most beautiful face in this course.
Um,
the bed is,
it would be all of you.
Ah,
wouldn't it be funny if I shouted out somebody's name
if I d I and,
and you know,
a,
I don't have the energy to do this.
And B,
it would probably violate 400 different privacy laws or whatever.
But if I took all those faces and morphed them together,
I would get a very pretty face.
And how do we know this while people have done this,
they've done it with.
So look at the faces from here to here.
And if you are like most people you see as you're going to the right,
they're looking better and better and better.
It's subtle,
but it's actually not so subtle that babies don't notice it.
The same researchers who constructed this,
these face,
these average Caucasian faces,
male and female,
have shown these faces to babies and find it.
Babies prefer to look at average faces suggested that our,
that our preference we're averaging is not the product of culture,
but rather it's to some extent hardwired.
These two people don't exist.
They're computer composites.
They're a heavily average male face and it heavily average female face,
both from our Caucasian data sample.
They don't look bad right there.
Good faces,
they,
they don't cheat.
So to hear for instance,
is,
is identical.
So they don't,
you can't use here cues,
but they're pretty attractive.
But a story of attractiveness does not end there.
How do you get a better than average face?
What can you do to these faces,
these average faces and make them look even better?
Well,
I'll have a vote.
Who's prettier?
Who says the one on the right
who says the one on the left left is average face and there might be variation
in his class or there definitely variations.
And what people favorite,
this is a feminized version of the average face.
We're certain protocol and features were made more feminine than average to
queue this as more of a sexual object.
This is a more complicated,
yeah.
Cool.
Who thinks the face,
who thinks face a is more attractive?
Who the face B is more attractive?
Okay.
Most people like face be.
The exception is,
and this has been statistically replicated I think now in three labs.
Um,
phase a is preferred by women who are ovulating.
And,
and the story about why is,
um,
is,
is complicated and will take us beyond the scope of this class.
But crudely,
the idea is that is that this is a really handsome guy.
He's young,
he's healthy,
he looks strong,
good provider.
This guy is really hot and,
and he may not be a good provider and everything,
but I'm sure he has wonderful genes.
So the idea is that one should have sex with him and then have him raise the
kids.
Okay.
We've talked so far about things about,
about sex and sexual attractiveness largely from a biological perspective,
looking at universals and in fact there are some universals in what men and
women have in common and what distinguished men and women and um,
and some of the sex differences,
particularly related to aggression,
uh,
and made preference seem to be universal.
They seem to show up to some extent across every culture you look at enhance are
likely candidates for biological adaptations.
But
there are other sex differences that people are aware of where the origins are
far less clear.
And I think that intelligent,
reasonable people could disagree about this,
but I am personally quite skeptical about the extent to which these reflect
biology.
I'm gonna I'll mention them to capture the debate,
but the thing to keep in mind here is that is that biology,
natural selection is one reason why the men in his class might differ from the
women in this class.
But of course there were other social factors.
Babies are treated differently.
There been many studies where you take a baby and you swaddle it and blue and
describe it as a boy versus swaddle it and pink and describe it as a girl.
And people treat it differently when they think it's a boy.
Then when they think it's a girl,
um,
you treated differently too.
It matters a lot.
And there's study after study suggesting for instance,
that when you send an email or a job application or a paper to a scientific
journal,
it matters whether it has the name John Smith on it versus the name Joan Smith.
It matters because people have different expectations in different reactions to
males versus females.
Some of you may have a firsthand experience with this.
If you're a man with a name that could be taken as a woman's name.
I'm a friend of mine,
his name Lynn,
and often people think he's female.
Or if you're a woman who has a name that could be taken as a man,
his name,
or if you have a name sufficiently foreign to western ears at that people can
easily tell you often find people saying,
oh,
people are high fiving each other there.
Um,
people
you'll often find some degree of surprise and some degree people saying,
oh my,
I didn't know you were a man.
Now I will treat you differently.
Um,
and so these social factors could play a role in explaining some male and female
differences.
Also rules of facts of gender,
self segregation.
So here's something very interesting happens developmentally.
Males segregate with other males.
Females segregate with other females for a period lasting,
it depends on the culture,
but say from age four to age 11,
this self segregation might exaggerate and enhance sex differences.
It might be,
for instance,
as Elanor McAbee has proposed that that boys are slightly more aggressive than
girls,
but then boys go into groups of boys and that enhances and exaggerates their
aggression.
Well the girls non aggressive behavior is enhanced and exaggerated in different
ways by them falling into girls' groups.
So what sort of differences are we talking about when we say we're not sure of
their costs?
Well,
one difference is one an empathy.
So Simon Baron Cohen wrote a wonderful book called the essential difference
where he argues that men are by nature less empathetic.
Women are by nature more empathetic.
Um,
and,
and that this is a core sex difference.
So what do you know?
Well,
what's the source for this?
One thing is men are more violent.
Simon Baron Cohen describes violence as the ultimate act murder as the ultimate
act of a lack of empathy.
Um,
there's some relationship between how much testosterone you have in your system
and how social you are.
More testosterone,
less social
boys tend to be less empathetic than girls.
And there's some evidence though it's not conclusive that boys do worst and
girls on social cognition theory of mind tasks.
That's what I have here though that is quite debated and the biggest effect,
which isn't debated at all.
His problems with empathy,
problems of social cognition,
um,
are much more frequent in men than women.
So this orders like autism,
Asperger's syndrome,
conduct disorder,
and psychopathy are predominantly male.
And Simon Baron Cohen suggests that,
um,
basically he has this slogan where he says to be a man is to suffer from a
particularly mild form of autism,
that males are just socially clueless relative to women.
Final bit of Trivia.
This is Simon Baron Cohen who is a very famous developmental psychologist,
but his cousin Sasha Baron Cohen is far more famous.
Um,
another debate is a debate concerning sex differences in their capacity for math
and science.
A few years ago there used to be a president of Harvard known as Larry Summers.
There's so many reasons to his at this point.
Um,
but,
and Larry Summers is no longer president of Harvard for various reasons.
But one reason was this quote,
which included in his speculations about sex differences in a special case of
science and engineering,
there are issues of intrinsic aptitude and particularly if the variability of
attitude.
He argued our suggested that the underrepresentation of women in the sciences in
academia is because of an intrinsic aptitude difference.
Women are on average,
less biologically predisposed to do this sort of reasoning.
The variability point is that he wasn't suggesting that if there's just a
difference on average,
in fact,
he agreed at the average skills and men and women are identical.
The claim is that male show more variation.
This means that there's more male retarded people and more males who were just
horribly bad at this,
but it also means there are more male geniuses.
And he suggested that this plays a role.
This,
as you can imagine,
proof to be an extremely controversial claim and rather than go through it
because it would take me a class to treat the pros and cons of this argument
responsibly.
Um,
I'm going to refer you to a wonderful debate between Steve Pinker,
who was quoted earlier and lists Belky who's one of the big infant,
uh,
cognition people.
And we,
we spoke a lot about her work earlier on in the course and they have a wonderful
debate between two of the smartest people I know.
I'm on the edge,
which was done at Harvard,
uh,
about a year ago and is on video here.
So if you're interested in sex differences and different theories about the
mechanism of sex differences,
this is where you should go.
Finally,
and the final topic,
some of us about 98% and the numbers are very difficult to pin down.
Maybe it is a 90%,
maybe it's 97,
maybe it's 99.
Let's say 98% of women are sexually attracted to men.
About 96% of men are sexually attracted to women.
And the number is very,
and it's very difficult to estimate a properly,
as you could imagine,
there's all sorts of problems with this sort of research,
but there's some proportion of population that's exclusively homosexual,
some proportion of population of men who are only attracted to other men,
some proportion of population of women who are only attracted to other women.
When people talk about sexual orientation here,
it's important to realize we are not talking here about behavior.
Um,
there's all sorts of reasons why somebody might have sex with somebody of the
same sex.
You know,
there might be bored,
you may,
you know,
be experimenting,
be whatever the question is,
what do you want to do?
All of these be w what,
what sort of person,
if you could be sexually or romantically involved with any person,
who would it be?
And most people are heterosexual.
There's a considerable amount at various cross culturally of people who are
bisexual.
But the real puzzle is exclusive homosexuality.
So why?
Well,
nobody knows.
We know.
Some reasons,
some answers are probably not right.
Um,
it is not the case almost certainly.
Maybe there are some exceptions,
but it is not the case that people choose your sexual orientation.
Um,
I'm not going to do this in this room,
but if I asked people to raise their hands as to how many people decided who to
become sexually attracted to,
very few people would,
um,
part of the issue rises in fact that that people who are gay are often extremely
discriminated against and they have no wish to be gay.
They might even think it's morally wrong for them to be that way,
that makes it implausible that their sexual orientation is a conscious choice.
What about experience after puberty?
So there is,
is a view that keeps coming up over and over again and literature that people
who are gay,
I have some sense been seduced by people,
by other people,
are something happened to him afterwards.
Um,
this seems unlikely.
Uh,
there are,
um,
in particular the seeds of,
of sexual orientation later on in life seem to show up quite early in life.
Again,
the studies are sort of suspect,
but there's some reason to believe that people who are gay and people who are
straight or different long before they hit puberty with regard to her sexual and
romantic fantasies,
you would now expect me to say,
well,
being gay and being straight,
it is built in.
It's hardwired.
None of these stories seem right.
It seems to be built in and answer to that is sort of,
so if you do the standard behavioral genetic tests and,
and you by now know how to do them,
you look for differences.
We knows I got can dies,
I got it.
Twins,
you do the adoption,
uh,
comparison,
you know,
adopted siblings and biological siblings.
The answer is yes.
You find that there is some sort of genetic predisposition towards
homosexuality,
but it can't be entirely genetic.
One reason why we can't,
it can't be entirely genetic is if I'm gay and I have an identical twin,
the odds that my identical twin will be gay.
It's about 50% those are very high odds compare to the average in the
population.
But if it was truly genetic,
entirely genetic,
what should the number be?
100% he's my clone.
He should be exactly as I am and it's not.
So we know then that some sort of experience,
possibly prenatal experience is what explains it.
Why is it,
so I said before,
this is a huge puzzle.
Why is it such a huge puzzle?
Well,
exclusive homosexuality is an evolutionary mystery.
Again,
do not think that this carries anymore or way to it.
Uh,
what it does mean though is that it doesn't seem to follow as a biological
adaptation.
The puzzle is not.
Why is it that some men have sex with men?
That's not a big puzzle.
Maybe they have sex with men as some sort of recreational thing,
our pair bonding or whatever.
That's not the puzzle.
The puzzle is why are there some men who don't want to have sex with women?
Similarly,
why are to some men,
women who don't want to have sex with men?
From an evolutionary adaptive standpoint,
you would think that the genes that give rise to such a behavior,
um,
would be weeded out because creatures with that behavior,
typically putting aside modern technology don't have offspring.
And that's what makes it such a puzzle.
So your reading response for this week is solve that puzzle.
I know is that early on in the course,
the reading responses would be really easy and just require you reciting back
things,
but that proved to be too boring,
so,
so just solve this deepest of all puzzles.
The thing in brackets at the end is very important.
Um,
your account,
whatever it is,
should bear some relationship to the facts as discussed in lectures and
readings.
Um,
we have about five more minutes.
Any questions or thoughts?
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Um,
she likes my leather jacket.
Yeah.
Any questions or thoughts?
Just like that one?
No.
Yes.
Right.
It's a good group on,
on a home,
on sexual preferences.
Um,
that's a very good question because certainly your answer to the origin gimme
two more minutes.
Certainly your answer about the origin of sexual preference in humans will be
informed by the question across species data.
What we do know is that there are many animals that engage in homosexual
behavior.
They engage in sex with members of their own sex.
What I don't know is whether you get exclusive homosexual behavior,
so I don't know what the rate is in nonhuman primates,
for instance,
of primates,
you do not want to have sex with members at opposite sex.
Okay,
I'll see you all Wednesday.